[Music]
in grandpa saves the day new [ __ ]
grandpa noise yeah you know that's all
my granny's I can always find my dad in
the supermarket buy his coffee
get a very specific old Asian coffe and
I'd be walking around to looking at toys
and sittin on it I would hear just I'm
like that's my dad I I was seven why the
[ __ ] do we become more more sick or the
older we become submitted by lost weeks
a grandfather stuck his leg out to trip
an armed robber which ended a dangerous
police pursuit wait oh [ __ ] and the
grand promise all he snapped his leg
[Laughter]
instead of using the Chi no wait a
minute wait a minute we all have been in
those moments of panic yeah just don't
[ __ ] have time to think like that
right he saved them actually the way he
did it he was just stretching even know
it was like you did it that way cuz he
kind of psyched out the dude so I'll
show you you'll see why thank you
here we go ready Wow good God Oh God
just then a quick thing and grandfather
with a cane literally steps in to trip
the man
boy you almost got shot police commander
Scott Hyland was on scene he says the
grandfather's quick thinking grandma
finesse that's it huh ballroom classes
no cuz I would have never thought to
back kick yeah grandpa was trying to get
out of the way right well smooth yeah
I'm gonna see that will fly again that
[ __ ] was whole way wow I never see
somebody fly that fast before
awesome his smooth screen dude he went
like that was so cool you see they were
they kick in the front and they step in
the back and then BOOM yeah like he
preps it that's what I'm saying like I
think I liked it better this way then if
you were to turn around use the cane
then the dude might have been like gosh
um I was thinking this like who yes
so the guy was running with a gun yeah
loaded gun between rounds 29 lots of
high-capacity Mariya yeah you had a
knife go good God gone god damn this
happened outside of a library in Ohio so
the grandpa people like good and they
toe the cop unit Ellen video with the
ages like this is library oh yes yes I
did
yes when they were like in a protest
yeah oh yeah
when do we want it no this is a library
he wants awful sassy yeah what is that
old you guys have to watch all that
there's that Lori Beth Denberg she was
in the light you remember the library
lady she would be like this it's a skin
on all that where this lady is library
lady she would be doing [ __ ] like she
would be like begging like making
popcorn or should be practicing the
drums within like anybody would whisper
and I was rude memory
this is library in the video
good one guys doing yeah uh she's off
the grandpa dude his name is Bill
last room but he was saying that he was
at the library with his granddaughter
and that's when he saw the suspect
running toward him and so he was he said
quote I had one opportunity and I had to
make the choice if I was going to act or
if I was going to be a bystander
I just stuck my foot out that's like
some M&M tabloids yeah one shot yeah you
know what have been awesome if he was a
Muay Thai guy and he just turned around
in a full roundhouse it's that guy
running he would have sliced it yeah you
got cool God yourself sesamoid china's
cuz you do more time i hope you love it
every sentence what's hot is this
because that thing is so devastating
yeah it's one of the most devastating
you should be proud of my people yeah i
am i always used to play with sun god on
his feet he's based off a real muy thai
fighter or is a legend yeah i think his
name is cigar is it's either as a
nickname or his last name the cigar yeah
I know he's based on real Thai fighter
yeah yeah yes again what time and he was
a giant back in the day really like he
was like five eight so back into that in
those days I was like really really talk
damn yeah that's crazy do that five
eight was considered really tall back in
the day
whoa big guy you know so that's that's
all you go through Abe Lincoln was like
what six two or some [ __ ] right yeah
I was like no just Alba hat he was like
he's be like five foot in that oh yeah
that must have been really tall Baghdad
yeah I didn't know he's like six four or
something oh really who Abe Lincoln he's
supposed to be [ __ ] tall this shit's
dumb or like extra small t-shirt there
was a [ __ ] president that shot
somebody's dick off what really I forgot
which president it was but it was like
one of my history teachers not to play
basically they had you know those those
shoe toss whether you would pay a duel a
duel yeah whatever paces turn around
right Oh was it audience Andrew Jackson
yeah I think it was Andrew Jackson and
then he you would shoot and so what
happens is if you shoot and you miss or
you don't the person doesn't die or
something you get a free shot anywhere
and that's like the the rules of
engagement so he chose to walk up and he
shot the dude in the dick more Dan yeah
can you like dodge it or you can know
you I don't know I'm so both both went
wrong and then he shot him but he lived
so if he be if he lives that he could
shoot that guy anyway I forgot what the
rules of engagement was but it allowed
him to shoot him anywhere on the body
and he shot him up that's probably like
you you're like dealer's choice
you know I'm saying like you can either
kill him or you can let him live yeah
they probably had like real beef yeah
it wasn't like to settle an argument or
some [ __ ] that's just crazy point I can
doall man and you got to keep a [ __ ]
pocket full of metal like marbles
[ __ ] gunpowder Alexander Hamilton and
[ __ ] yeah I remember because of that
that [ __ ] milk commercial yeah
the classic gas commercial kids oldest
viewers this guy worked at a museum with
all this like Aaron Burr maybe was
museum maybe was his house he had a
bunch of just like Aaron Burr
memorabilia all right and then so the
potential the radio is like here's a
contest trivia question you win whatever
if you can answer this question who
killed Alexander Hamilton so he looks
like she's the painting up two guys
dueling and then he's like but he's
eating a peanutbutter sandwich and then
so like he's like calling it he runs to
the kitchen to get milk oh he was trying
to wash it down so he doesn't have it
you can't answer the question he doesn't
win the money like he's stupid cuz he
could have used a [ __ ] see ya or see
read it out oh yeah not sink yeah do
they still have those God milk
commercials I don't think so no I felt
you and I do the ads like Matt grant
yeah yeah but I think Dan that was a
good one does that mean all the dairy
farmers like joint forces and they're
like alright we're all gonna make these
got no commercials yeah how does that
work cuz it was never like a specific
brand of the knows a government thing
it's a government thing it could have
been the day farmers lobbied the
government to make one of my other
favorite got no commercials this is more
reason I don't know size also they still
do have cotton this is not recent reason
but recenter more so it's like the
little game who didn't want to drink
milk and he's like and and then and then
the moms like how about old men know
that kids like old man Jerry he's never
had a outs of milk in his life he's
still super strong he's mowing the lawn
and he like moves and his arms break off
forgot about that [ __ ] was [ __ ] funny
dude that's not funny Super Bowl Super
Bowl just Google Got Milk commercial
2018 it seems like they still do it oh
damn but well I don't watch TV yeah who
does you know I just miss commercials
man get cable so Super Bowl commercials
have gotten progressively more wack
there's always like the occasional dope
one and
SR like man I used to be excited for
Super Bowl commercials even more so than
the game you know I just loved watching
this that was like overhyped
Super Bowl commercial the dancing baby I
didn't get it yeah baby it was like oh
the uber choco I didn't get it
yeah why did they get so popular I don't
know no no no God Chuck oh yeah it is
that telecast uh wait is that is that
super commercial was that from Ally
McBeal I used to watch alan McBeal and
this is why he was kind of popping this
little baby she was even ran a baby if
she was it was random dancing baby this
is what we're talking about that is the
same one though like he just got so big
I don't know why
hung on a bathing oh my god I love this
song only because the guardians of the
galaxy ah yeah every branded that's all
you ain't seen affinity war yeah shake
my head they're in it yeah they're in it
oh it's some crazy [ __ ] happen some
battles this chin looks weird it looks
like a mud print of a shoe or something
I don't know what the who Thanos is chin
makes me freaking out a little
who's your favorite character from all
from everyone in there just everybody in
the whole world in the whole Marvel
Cinematic Universe like everyone that's
in infinity war
there's Wolverine in there I'll go say
you know there's no x-men in the year
and in that there's no x-men yeah
because like it's because of the
studio's way some [ __ ] it's like
different Studios own different parts
yeah yeah
damn it mr. Stoll Marvel well they
should have made him off Franzen [ __ ]
yeah I like we're gonna get my movie Oh
for reals I hate them
[Music]